when I recorded my HBO special
afterwards I went out and partied with a
few of the production people and stuff
like that and I got too drunk and so I
went out to McDonald's I wanted 20
nuggets in a box a whole lot of sauces
right but they don't have 20 boxes in
America they have 20 now they'd be yeah
but back then yeah the 20 bucks wasn't
in America and I so drank that they gave
me 26 boxes of nuggets
like that and I just had these two bags
and I didn't even question I just picked
them up like also I was so drunk that it
was like and that's 98 please I was like
what the [__] American McDonald's is
expensive
and I was running on the street with my
26 boxes
20 bucks 120 nuggets yeah 120 nuggets
they said what sauce they said give me a
bit of everything so there was another
like bag full of sauce so I was in this
big penthouse suite in New York that HBO
gave me and I woke up Jazz [__]
surrounded by nuggets all over the bed
it's like hero to zero